Hello everybody! Before we get started, I wanted to let you guys know that the tickets for the tour are on sale now.
If you go to markiplier.com, or the link in the description below (because it's the same place), you can find all of the cities that
we're going to, and all of the ticket sales are right there on the website. Check it out, let me know what you think, and
thanks for watching. Here's the video! *gibberish*
Seizure warning: This game has a lot of flashing colors and lights, no joke, lots of them. Big seizure warning.
Big as can be. *gibberish*
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome to "v". Now this game is interesting just because- oh?
"Red", "Green", I like that show when it was on the TV channel tube thing. "Blue".
I'm feeling blue. "Cyan", okay. "Purple".
"Yellow". "Red". *static sound*
Ooooookay.
Alright, okay, alright.
Okay. Ah!
I get it. I'm supposed to left-click when it's the right color to the right name
and right-click when it's the wrong to the right.
Okay. Oh!
Did I pass the test "v"?
Did I pass the "v" test?
Okay, alright. Well, don't come any closer. Please, don't do that, okay? Oh!
"You are a gifted child, sitting in front of a TV screen."
- Am I now?
- Don't call me a child.
"You will use your intelligence to switch through every channel on the planet." Oho.
America Samoa; Achievement Unlocked! Uh...
The cookie is blue- No!
That was cyan!
I goofed it, "V".
I'm sorry, "V".
I'm so sorry.
Oh
Achievements... Connect to Oceania.
Oh!
Oh...
Ah...
(shuddering)
Oh
Ah-oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no- this is deeper.
Number 3: The Cook is...
I don't know...
(sing-song)
I don't know!
Okay.
I don't know what nausea does, but I keep it on, I guess?
I don't know- okay.
Here we go.
"Connecting to Oceania".
Let's do this!
Red, Cyan, no, yes...
Yes
No, yes, yes, no
Yes, yes- my brain is breaking. My brain is breaking!
Ah, no!
No!
Oh... I got to Asia!
No, yes.
I don't know!
No, yes, yes, no, no, no, yes, no
Oh, my God! My brain!
Yes!- oh, my God. Okay, I-I couldn't quite tell what that one.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, no, yes, yes, yes- God, I pr-
Fuck! That was really green!
Ahhhh!
TV?  Oh, TV #50 Oman.
I got to Oman!
Oh my god.
Oooooooooooooookay.
Here we go!
I gotta go through Oceania again?
Oh, blue? Yeah.
Okay, yeah. Okay. Alright.
Yup, yuppers, yuperoonie.
Yuppadiddle. Yupondo. Yupaneebo.
Nope! Ah...
Super yep!
Not yep!
Yep-yep!
Yeppy-yep!
Yepperdooper!
Nope-nope!
Yeppy doop!
Yep-yep!
[Gasp]
"Connecting to Asia". Okay, if I can't-
If I don't let my brain break and I show how smart I "is"...
maybe I'm gonna get something here.
Yup!
Okay, no, yes.
Ugh.
Yes!
No!
No.
Yes!
No-oh!
Oh, my God! I almost messed up there!
Ehh...
Frick-a, frick-a yes!
Oh, my god!
I don't know if I have a time limit on this thing- it's gettin' REAL nauseous in here!
No! Yes! No! Yes!
No!
Yes.
Yes!
No!
Yes! Yes!
Ah! I made it to Europe!
Oh, my God. Yes! Yes!
Yes! No! No!
Oh! Wait. Oh, you fucked me.
'Kay, alright.
N-n-noooooooo!
I don't know what you did to me and why you did that!
DTV?
Down To Victory?
Dab *snickers* to victory?
Nah, that ain't it.
Freaking dick.
Ah!
Ahh...
Well, I'm almost completing the game in dooder.
"Achieve Sherlock Mode"?!
What is "Sherlock Mode"?!
(crying)
I don't know what "Sherlock Mode" is...
I don't know what any of this is.
I'm gonna turn off "nausea".
And, also
Obviously, there's a Seizure Warning on this one.
Let's turn off "nausea", 'cause it's nauseous.
Eh, "start at Asia"? I'll do that.
Thanks.
All right. Okay, here we go.
Starting at Asia now.
Yellow, green, no, yes, yes, no
Cyan, red, no, red, blue
No, no, no
Cyan, red, no, yes, yellow, no, no, no
No, no, yes!
Green, no, blue, no, red, yellow, green, yellow
Ah, frick!
(sing-song)
I don't like this very much. It is-
Ha-ah- okay.
(sing-song)
Yes, yes, no, no, yes, yes, yes, no.
I'm clicking "Cyan"
No
Oh, yeah
Oh, God.
I don't know what happened there, but I think I did it.
Was that Sherlock Mode?
It sure didn't feel like Sher-LOCK!
It felt like stu-PID!
"Inverted controls"? I didn't want that!
Oh, no!
I didn't know that was a thing!
I didn't know that was a thing.
I went to Lithuania!
It was all the way to Lithuaniaaaa...
Yes, yes, no, no, no.
Yes, yes, no, no.
Oh, yes, yes, no
I don't know why is that- why is that going all crazy on me?
Yee- okay.
Crazy, okay.
Yeesh, it's gonna go Detective Mode, I know that.
Yes, yes- my brain is slowing down; I can actually feel my brain physically slowing down in crippling doubt.
My, my-my entire body.
Ahh! Oh, frick!
I just-
Second chance. You got a second chance - that's fine
Let's go. Let's do this.
Wait- what does that mean?
What did the second chance do?
Did it do nothing?!
Did I have to click on it?
God, that looks blue!
Ah, it looked blue!
Fuck, a duckle! God, I'm getting too quick about it. My brain's not keeping up with my hand.
Red, yellow, green, cyan
No, no, no, red, cyan, red, no, green, cyan, no
No, yellow, green, no, green, blue, green, no, cy-
Ah...!
This is hard.
Argh, God!
Pfffft...
Pfff, right off the bat. I didn't even get a chance.
Whoa!
That's what it is! You can click as many times as you need...!
Okay. All right. Okay.
Blue, green, no, yellow, blue-
God, it looks blue!
Okay, I don't know what that means: "Inverted Controls"
You're trying to fuckle with me and I ain't playing your fuckle-duckle bullshit!
There we go. Got it. I got you. You think you got me, but you don't, 'cause I'm smart and you're dumb, and we're
gonna win this, and I'm gonna win this, and that's cyan, that green, that's red, that's yellow, that's red, that's not...
Yeah, it's over to the good shit in the Americas.
All right, here we go! Inverted? Blam! Got it. Inverted? Hm, blam! Got it
Inverted? Oh, fuck. Yeah, no, red
Green, cyan
No, red
Cyan, no
Red, yellow
I don't know what that was!
Right- oh! Why my finger twitched?!
Ah! Piss...
Ooh! Okay. Ooh, fuck. Man, those inverted upside-downs ain't so- I didn't do anything
Ahh, frick. You are messing with me.
Okay. God, damn it
I lo-
Okay. All right. Well, then.
Stop doing that!
Gotta give me my- Ahh, freaking
Freakin'
Fricker
Frick
Frickydicky, freak-a-frick-a
Whoaaaaa...!
Africa...!
Uhhh yeah
(sing-song)
Not today
Inverted controls- it always gets me! Ah...
Fuck that, the inverted God-damn controls
Iyi
Yi
Okay!
No, no, no, no, no, no, yes
Fuck, I hate this!
Oh, my God!
Okay. Alright. We're doing okay.
Heh booskie!
No
Ne-ugh
Ah, but it wasn't blue when I left-clicked!
*video game audio* Dad?
*video game audio* I'm scared. I can't find mum or anyone at home.
I-I did it?
(dial-up modem sound in the background)
I did it!
Oh, I did it.
Holy crap, I did it.
"Reach number 200 on Saturn"
I don't know what that is.
Okay, but that is the end of this- so far, I think.
Oh, no, I don't want to go back in!
I'm gonna fail you!
Okay.
All right. So, anyway. I'm gonna leave this at that before my brain melts.
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
Let me know what you thought of this down in the comments below.
This is super fun, by the way, it's-it's a weird skill.
It's like one of those skills, like, you don't think you'd ever need, but still, it's really, really, cool.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching! Let me know what you think down in the comments below,
and, as always, I will see you in the next video!
Buh-bye!